Let's switch gears and talk a little bit about sleep and dreaming, and how that
relates to our consciousness. So why do we sleep? Is our brain responsive while
we sleep? Can we hear while we sleep? Can we be consciously aware of our
dreams? All of these are types of questions that psychologists have researched
for a really long time. And we're going to go over a few of the answers in this
section of the lesson. We're going to look at the biological purpose of sleep.
What happens during sleep, and what happens if we don't get enough sleep? I
promise you, it's not good, because sleep is imperative for us to function as
healthy human beings. We really need sleep for both our physical and mental
health. So let's start by looking at our sleep patterns.